wait is this star wars
oh yeah i guess it is it's just going to
be going in a completely different
direction than any other star wars story
we've seen before we're gonna get wall-e
droids we're gonna get bell towers from
game of thrones and we're gonna get
sardikar throat singing like from doom
this new series streaming august 31st on
disney plus will completely change the
star wars galaxy as we know it diego
luna the actor playing cassian andor on
the show recently let us know that we
might not even recognize his character
at the beginning but what exactly does
he mean by that
andor stars diego luna as the spy who
sacrificed himself in 2016's rogue one
while stealing the plans for the death
star on scarif
this story will be completely different
from anything else we've seen in the
star wars galaxy so far though because
it'll show us a side that isn't usually
seen as being family friendly it'll
likely show the wars aspect of star wars
in greater detail we're going to get to
see the darker grittier side of star
wars probably similar in some ways to
rogue one diego luna even said that the
show will take place in the darkest
times the galaxy has ever seen before
make sure to stay until the end of the
video for the biggest piece of
information we've received on the show
though luna said we may not recognize
his character at the beginning of the
show most likely because he starts out
as a thief simply angry at the empire
with no greater purpose or cause to get
behind throughout the show we'll likely
see cassian grow into the man who
sacrificed his life for the sake of the
rebellion in rogue one and it's this
kind of intense growth that we've seen
very little of in recent star wars
stories one of the biggest differences
that the series will bring to the star
wars galaxy is that we'll actually get
to see the formation of the rebellion
against the empire something we've never
seen in depth before yes we've seen
certain aspects of it in the animated
series rebels but that show focused
mostly on the crew members of the ghost
rather than on the actual formation of
the rebellion this is one era of star
wars lore where there isn't much
information available so it'll be really
interesting to see how everything
started before a new hope one thing the
series will show us is the difference
between man mothma as the incorruptable
leader of the rebel alliance and cassian
andor as the rebel spy who typically
finds himself in gray areas and
questionable circumstances it'll likely
hit on similar themes to ones we've seen
in previous star wars stories such as
the desire to find balance as cassian
strives to find a balance between doing
what needs to be done and doing the
right thing in any given situation he'll
likely face the struggle between doing
what he thinks is right and doing
whatever it takes to bring down the
empire similar to some of the themes
present in rogue one
in a recent interview with vanity fair
diego luna said i believe science
fiction and stories that happen in a
galaxy far far away are a great tool to
comment on our world on your life and my
life and the way we interact we need to
explore the revolutionary we can become
to change things to stop war to make
this world a livable place so andorr
talks about that i think it can inspire
a lot of people on how much you can do
by yourself it'll be really interesting
to see how the show brings this idea to
life especially given its departure from
the typical star wars formula the series
has been described as a tense spy
thriller more akin to something like
james bond than star wars this might be
one of the most important aspects of
this video rather than a futuristic
fantasy story set in outer space we're
gonna be getting mission impossible
meets dune and i think that might
actually be a good thing if lucasfilm
were to keep giving us the same type of
story over and over it might start to
feel a bit stale now that we're getting
something that fits into somewhat of a
different genre than what we're used to
we can start to see star wars in a
different light that might open it up to
a completely new audience
now the biggest piece of information
we've received on the show which may be
a little bit of a spoiler is that man
mothma may not be the perfect moral
driven character that we think she is
the show's director tony gilroy hinted
that we may even have been lied to in
previous star wars stories or given a
different version of the events from how
they truly happened also hinting that
fans will likely have a lot to say about
mon mothma gilroy said what you know
what you've been told what's on
wikipedia what you've been telling each
other is really all wrong
so in all likelihood we may find that
mod mothma has more extremist tendencies
than we originally thought perhaps
somewhat like saw gerrera a rebel
extremist who would stop at nothing to
bring down the empire one criticism i've
heard about the show is that it seems
unnecessary since we know how cassian's
story ends in rogue one i would disagree
though because with that mentality we
wouldn't have gotten the clone wars or
rebels or any of the prequels i think
there's so much to cassie and andor that
we haven't seen yet and tons of
backstory missing at this point in the
star wars timeline although we know how
cassian's story ends on scarif there's
plenty of chapters within his story
we'll get to explore in the series and i
can't wait to see how it unfolds but let
me know what you think will andor be
taking star wars in the right direction
drop your thoughts in the comment
section below also check out the video
on your screen for some different
content don't forget to like and
subscribe and thanks for watching rocket
rightly
[Music]